as Ukraine liberates more of its
territory from Russia what does this
mean for Vladimir Putin
he could retrench and regroup building
up more defensive positions on land that
he currently holds that might involve
retreating from some areas but it would
make it easier to defend resupply and
possibly attack from the territory that
he holds but his biggest problem is
Manpower and morale amongst his troops
on the battlefield what can he do about
that how does he replenish those forces
too
he could call for a full mobilization or
probably more likely a partial
mobilization because a full mobilization
calling all Russia's young men into the
fight would be politically extremely
risky even then a partial mobilization
though would take some time to retrain
his reservists and he doesn't have much
time right now
that is the fear and Vladimir Putin has
made it clear time and again how big and
powerful his nuclear Arsenal is
still using a nuclear weapon is quite
the Rubicon to cross and he would have
to feel that he'd exhausted all other
options Russia's nuclear Doctrine
clearly states that it can only strike
first if the security of the state is at
risk
now the rhetoric that you're hearing
increasingly on state TV is that this
whole operation is to defend Russia
against an aggressive West and
aggressive NATO out to annihilate the
Russian state but still it is quite a
stretch and there's nothing to say that
the use of a tactical nuclear weapon
would be the definitive Game Changer on
the battlefield
this is a police state where the
security services hold Civil Society in
a straight jacket it is very difficult
to conjure up any form of resistance in
Russia right now you just have to hold
up a blank piece of paper and you can be
detained it may well be that there are
factions within the elites who aren't
that happy with what's going on but
they're keeping a pretty low profile for
now it would seem that the man in the
Kremlin is sitting pretty sweet
foreign
it's an unlikely scenario but anything
is possible the question is who would
succeed him and when many here in
politics have grown up in a system where
power is secured by the security
services you might just end up getting
more of the same
Vladimir Putin has not lost a ward that
he's been directly involved with during
his time in office chechnya was
eventually brought into submission after
a long and brutal campaign the war in
Georgia ended in a matter of days after
Georgian forces retreated
and Russia's intervention in Syria to
prop up Syrian leader Bashar al-assad
turned the war in his favor and he's
still in office
so will Ukraine buck that Trend Vladimir
Putin probably thought that Ukrainian
forces might retreat in the way that
Georgian forces did he was wrong about
that